so what we're going to talk about today
is something pretty close to my own work
and it's this question that has arisen
about asking about iteration right so
you and i have talked about like the
mandelbrot set and all of these things
that i'm really interested in that have
to do with iteration
and how it interacts with fractions with
rational numbers all right so here is
where we start which is where we seem to
always start which is with z squared
plus c so i'm interested in the function
which takes in a number z squares it and
then adds some constant c and so we've
looked at this kind of thing before but
just to take a quick look at some of the
behavior that occurs so for example like
if c is equal to one and let's say we
start with the number zero then if i
repeatedly apply this rule if i iterate
the function then let's see what happens
so zero maps to zero squared which is
zero plus one so that's the first
iteration now i take one and i put it
right back into the formula so i square
it and i add the value which is one
so one plus one that's two i take two i
squared and i add one that's five i take
five i square it i add one that's what
26 and so on uh you're not going to do
the next one i think it's 677 but
we'll check all right we should check
later
okay so that's getting big time so it's
getting big right yeah so this is
actually a really good point this is
exactly what i want to talk about is
that if you just randomly do this choose
some number c
choose some numbers to start with and
iterate under this formula
kind of what happens a lot of the times
with a lot of the ones you try is these
get really big or maybe they get really
small but in any case what often happens
is when you do this process you end up
with different numbers at each stage you
never come back to zero for example
and so if you do though
so let's see an example where you do so
if c is equal to zero
for example that's supposed to be a zero
so c is equal to zero and i put in zero
so now we're looking at the map which
takes z and just maps it to its square
right
then if i put zero in well i square it i
get zero right back out and so i don't
get this nice infinite list of numbers i
just end up back right where i started
so this is called being periodic by the
way a number is periodic for this
function if when i put it in and then
iterate like this i end up back where i
started i mean you gave a really easy
example there do we get examples where
it can be like 30 steps and then comes
back so this is exactly the question i
want to ask so okay just to do a few
more examples before i get to 30.
um looking at this case of c equals zero
just to make it clear i don't have to
choose zero here right like if i put the
number one into z maps to z squared then
one maps to one squared which is still
one
so it's possible for something to be
periodic even if it's not today starting
at this point zero okay
so here's the question which is exactly
what you asked which is
can we keep doing this but in a more
interesting setting so not just
returning right away but after say five
steps or 30 steps or whatever coming
back to a number that we started with
and to make this question interesting i
want to be able to do it with a number
that's easy for me to write down ie with
a fraction so that's the question i want
to be able to answer isn't it an integer
easier than a fraction an integer is
easier than a fraction but we're going
to run into trouble right away with
integers
so there's not that many examples with
integers and you can kind of see why if
you look at this z squared example so
what i did works for zero and one but
for any other integer okay forget minus
one for second any other positive
integer
if i plug it into this and when it gets
a number which each time is larger and
larger and larger and larger so i can
never come back i can never have a
periodic integer other than these ones
so
yes it would be simpler but it's so
simpler that it's not going to happen
all right you can have fractions there
all right thank you okay so the first
thing to point out is that it can happen
with fractions so let's say c is equal
to one quarter now if i start with zero
what happens is well i get zero squared
plus one quarter one quarter squared
which is one over sixteen plus one
quarter which i guess is 5 over 16. and
anyways it's not as easy it's not as
obvious
in the case when c was equal to 1 but 0
is not going to come back to itself
we're going to get more and more
complicated fractions each time and so
we can't get back to zero
but if instead we start with that equals
one half then if we take one half and we
square it
and we add one quarter we end up right
back where we started so we found
another example
of something that just comes right back
to itself
but is a fraction so it can happen for
fractions and the good news is that
it's not just coming right back to
yourself immediately that happens
so if say c is equal to
minus 1
then actually zero does this because
zero squared minus one
is minus one
and minus one
squared minus one
takes us right back to zero so the
number of integers that we see here or
fractions that we see here can be higher
than one at least so here we just have a
number going back to itself so we only
see a single number when we iterate
here we see two numbers when we iterate
it's possible to see three i think it's
c is equal to
minus 29 over 16 and you start with
z equals minus seven fourths
which we've actually talked about this
number before it's kind of a tricky one
in dynamics what was your first video i
know i know reminiscing about the days
all right so if we start with say z
equals minus seven fourths oh man i
really don't wanna do these computations
but let's do it
so minus seven fourths when i square
this i get 49 over 16 and then i
subtract
29 over 16.
that's 20 over 16 otherwise known as
5 over 4. now when i take 5 over 4 and i
square it i get 25 over 16 and then i
subtract 29 over 16 i get minus 4 over
16 otherwise known as minus one quarter
and if i remembered the values correctly
when we do this to minus one quarter we
should end up back where we started
so if i take minus one quarter and i
square it i get 1 over 16 and then i
subtract 29 over 16
what i end up with is minus 28 over 16
which hey okay good really is minus
seven quarters where you started where i
started so for this particular value of
c we can have
three
fractions when we iterate minus seven
quarters goes to five quarters goes to
minus one quarter
which takes us back where we started
all right okay four four
i'm done
that's it
we can't do it for four
we can't do it for five
we don't think we can do it for six
and we have no idea about more
also
four and five proven can't be done
proving can't be done right
but for higher than that
we don't know for sure so your question
initially about 30 i have no idea how to
answer it if i had to take a guess
i would say no way
two and three are there an infinite
number of ways to do it or oh that's a
really good question and the answer is
yes yeah so there are an infinite number
of ways there's a really complicated
formula in the case when you're taking
three that tells you exactly which
values of c and exactly which values of
z achieve this but there is a way to do
it
have you caught the numberphile podcast
yet our latest guest is holly who you
just saw in this video you can find out
more about her career life and
mathematics how she got to where she is
it's a really interesting listen i try
not to read youtube comments
the more important thing is i always
tell my family members more to read
youtube
do they read what do they do do they
email you and say they did on the first
video and then they promptly stopped
and if you'd like to see more videos
with holly there are links to that on
the screen as well and the fact that we
just don't know i mean i get frustrated
by that fact
but i think it's really interesting
about like sort of what is a hard
problem in mathematics